first of all this was a great experience
and and thanks of tranfer for
and I was a little skeptical honestly
one the first time that that's really
approached me saying you first of all
you're not gonna convince these many
people to come in to the same place at
the same time do that and second of all
I'm sure there's gonna be a you know
interesting fistfight but nothing
nothing more than that
turns out I ain't seen much in the way
of fistfights I'm not sure that people
necessarily have changed their mind I
know I have not significantly moved from
my initial positions but on the other
hand I wasn't expecting that I think
that's unreasonable I mean most people
most powerful people change their mind
after a while that they cut to date on
things you know this is one more
experience that puts input into my brain
both conscious and unconscious and and
eventually I'll you know I keep thinking
about Eddie you keep being exposed to
different views of the different ways of
presenting this I'm used by different
people and sometimes you do change your
mind about things I certainly have
learned a lot about people positions I
have identified two or three areas where
I think actually I'm stronger in my
position than I was before and I have
identified one or two areas what I need
to be concerned and think about it so in
the other thing I think that we
shouldn't really underestimate even
though it does sound sort of
touchy-feely it was nice to actually see
people in person and and have a beer
with Jerry last night and you know just
chat with Alex at the same time the same
table net sort of stuff just to mention
two of my usual you know antagonistic I
guess it's one way to put it because
that way you know you put a human face
on things and the next time you you
attack the ideas but you're more careful
about attacking the person which I think
it's something that I personally strive
for but sometimes I fail so in terms of
that sort of general ideas it seems to
me clear that I need to be more about
more in the in the philosophy of physics
the primarily physical literature in
physics particular in quantum mechanics
it's a little difficult so I might
actually ask people for suggestions for
you know second level
you know sources but I find that that
area actually very interesting as far as
of course it's relevant to almost
everything we've discussed today because
it goes at the roots of what does it
mean to be a naturalist to be a
determinist and to be a reductionist and
those are clearly philosophical
questions that are informed not much by
biology as much as by fundamental
physics so that's what I need to
concentrate more of more efforts at the
same time I think I think that that I've
been made to think about things like
like the freewill debate I think I'm now
convinced that we really need to stay
away from that term I mean I've actually
you know this is in agreement huge area
yes it was well it was a partial shift I
mean I've actually thought about that
before but but this this time is
definitely put me over the edges and you
know I really really should try to avoid
that that anything because it's just not
helped not the topic obviously that the
term because it's really not not helpful
and I guess however in terms of sort of
substance I confirm myself closer to a
guest dance position or some variation
there thereof in terms of what I
actually think about that
I still yes that's okay I don't have a
lot else to say at the moment the other
thing that I'm concerned about about is
that this whole thing of about emergence
I think that we have not explored in now
non-mystical numb miss Julian
interesting ways in which you can talk
about emergence which I think are there
out there there's at least a couple
different ways for instance the word
supervenience has never come up which is
kind of interesting supervenient is what
after if in there is at shipping I
actually I also don't think it's
particularly useful in discussing
emergence because it actually deals with
a very weak version of emergence but it
should have come up at least even even
just as a ESPYs
I mean there are interesting areas they
are in the philosophy of physics where
where we could go back and revisit that
topic and yes I will come back to
something like this perhaps more focused
on a subset of of topics
you